the hip-hop artist common is known for
incorporating activism into his work
he's featured in the critically
acclaimed new film they hate you give
this is a knockout movie actress Amandla
Stenberg Stenberg plays star with two
R's carter a teenager was forced to find
her voice after watching a white police
officer shoot her childhood friend this
actress got her big break as rue and the
mega hit The Hunger Games and she was
also featured in Beyonce's lemonade
visual album I remember that our
confronts her uncle a police officer
played by common about what goes through
the mind of an officer a lot goes
through a cop's mind when they pulled
someone over especially if they have to
get into a pissing contest with the
driver about why they stopped him it
sets off an alarm are they hiding
something is the car stolen but you
still don't know if they did anything
wrong that's why we searched him but if
they open the door or reach through an
open window they're probably going for a
weapon so if I think I see a gun I don't
hesitate
I shoot because you think you see a gun
you don't say something first like put
your hands up common and Amandla
Stenberg join us at the table good
morning to you both that is such a
pivotal scene because how he answers
that question really changes a little
bit there there a relationship in the
movie what I like guys is that the
dialogue is so real in this movie common
yeah well me first of all Angie Thomas
who wrote that wrote an incredible book
it's been on a New York Times
bestsellers list for like 75 weeks but
the facts you know you know George
Tillman our director and and our writer
who wrote the script like I feel like
they captured what the way people talk
human beings talking I think most
importantly too we were able to really
get to the core of the truth of what
these characters were playing it it was
important for uncle Carlos and who I
play and star to have that honest
conversation about what it is to be a
black police officer you know what guys
I thought we know this story because
it's in the news all the time but we
didn't know this particular story
because your dad in the movie is a
former gang member you witnessed this
and your dad is encouraging you to tell
the truth which is sort of unheard in
the culture about snitching yeah I mean
it would definitely I think what can be
powerful about it is how media tends to
misconstrue blackness hopefully we can
postulate it in a way that's truthful
and honest and we're allowed to be open
and candid and multi-dimensional common
you talked about the difficulty of
portraying black police officers what is
the truth of that well the truth is
they're human beings and in every and
it's just like we don't want to
stereotype black people we don't want to
stereotype all police as bad but we do
have to recognize that it's something in
a system that has allowed the police
officers to shoot unarmed black and
brown people and we have that risk
perspective understand that that's the
problem but at the same token we got to
figure out solutions and the reason why
I was important for me to play these
characters I feel like understanding
both sides is one of the ways we get to
resolution and we have to listen to each
other and figure out the best ways to
get to it like a peaceful place you view
the role that the police officers play
in society differently now after this
movie I do to a certain degree on me I
still like there's no excuses for
unarmed people being shot 16 times I
mean we can name so many people yeah yes
so I think I do understand that that's
the beauty of acting you get to
understand people's positions even more
so I do respect to understand that like
I said police officers are not all bad
that would be a
I think I even think of but I'm like
what are we gonna do to solve this now
like what are we doing
like as a community as as politicians to
just make sure we appoint people who are
looking to progress this movement it's
beautiful beautifully active and acted
in the reviews are incredible variety
says the film is entertaining enraging
and poised to be a hit and Rolling Stone
described your performance Amandla as
quote a Gathering Storm that grows in
ferocity and the feeling with each scene
through you you're trying to in some
ways in part a message yeah yeah
absolutely and part of a message and
hopefully even empower voices
particularly those that have been
disenfranchised especially including
young black women not because we really
made this film for them and Angie wrote
the book but your character star used to
call her star 2.0 because she lives in a
black neighborhood but she goes to a
white school and Angie that was how she
grew up - she said she would leave the
house listening to Tupac but she get to
school listening to the Jones talk about
that for your character and she has a
white boyfriend in the movie there was
so many very interesting details yeah I
mean she's a nuanced black person you
know living in contemporary black
experience he's something that we often
have to do as coats which depending on
the environment that we're in because we
understand that blackness is not
necessarily accepted into all the spaces
that we enter into and so sometimes it's
necessary to be very intentional with
how we present ourselves in order to
achieve some sort of success you know
because we understand that sometimes our
blackness can be misconstrued as
detrimental well the movie opens limited
this week because you you got to stiff
competition but you've got a bigger
release coming because word of mouth is
gonna sell this movie yeah we thank you
both for being here
powerful movie they hate you give opens
in selected cities today